the suspect accused of stabbing two men
to death and seriously injuring a third
on a Portland Oregon train is due in
court today President Trump called these
attacks unacceptable he tweeted this the
victims were standing up to hate and
intolerance
Mireya Villarreal is outside the
Multnomah County Justice Center with how
a bystander helps say the third victims
life Mireya good morning to you well
good morning Gail this morning Jeremy
Christian is set to be arraigned in
court on several charges including
murder but this morning we are learning
more about the lone survivor in this
attack and the man who helped him in the
situation micah came running out holding
the left side of his neck going somebody
help me call 911
marcus knife was waiting for the train
with his family friday afternoon when he
suddenly heard people screaming and
running for safety that's when he
spotted 21-year old Michael Fletcher one
of three good Samaritans who police say
was stabbed by Jeremy Christian while
defending two young teens during a
racist rant I wrapped my hand over his
to try and keep pressure on his neck and
then somebody tossed us a little toddler
jacket to put over the wound Micah's
family credits the Iraq war veteran with
keeping the college student alive he'll
be with us forever
he's his life saver micah is now
recovering at home the two other men who
stood up against Christian 23 year old
Tilly Samir denim Kiamichi and 53
year-old Army veteran Ricky best died
from their injuries clearly what
happened on that train was an act of
terrorism what happened on that train
was a hate crime Portland mayor Ted
wheeler says he hopes the tragedy will
inspire change he's calling on the
federal government to revoke the permit
for a rally later this week organized by
the same alt-right group that planned
the protest where Christian went on a
hate-filled rent last month
yes it's protected by the First
Amendment of the Constitution but I'm
also asking people to use common sense
and have some decency out of respect for
the fact that this community is still
mourning and we're
still angry the rallies organizer right
now says he does not promote hate speech
and he is not associated with Jeremy
Christian at this point right now he is
not cancelling his event the ACLU was
also weighed in on this debate their
director saying that government
censorship is not the answer charlie so
far more than a million dollars has been
raised online for the victims and their
families thanks Maria